this is
a serious story that's been circulating
and already the internet is up in arms
over whether or not they believe it with
many people who are pro-israel saying
how could you not the reporting coming
out that babies had been beheaded by
Hamas and it sounds so extreme it is I
mean this in the literal sense it is
unbelievable but uh Fox News is
reporting it I24 initially reported it
and there are many people who are
skeptical of this um because of uh past
testimony The Near Year testimony in
particular uh back during I think it was
in the early 90s when a young woman
claimed that sanam's forces were taking
babies out of incubators so we're going
to talk about the news that's coming out
and obviously this is a very very
complex issue that is extremely heated
but of course it is now on the Forefront
as US Special Forces are offering
assistance over the hostages who have
been taken by Hamas which Biden says
many may be American citizens of course
there was a carrier group dispatched and
fears that this could escalate into a
more serious conflict and if we're
seeing conflict now escalating to the
point of us or other countries
mobilizing you know maybe we're we're we
at the point where we might say World
War III they've been saying that about
Ukraine for some time now but when we
get you know Conflict at this level in
various regions if China then moves on
Taiwan things get really really bad so
we'll talk about that plus uh several
other stories but for the most part I
mean this is the News That's dominating
right now uh before we get started my
friends head over to cast brew.com you
like coffee I know you do we got coffee
you want to buy it from us cbw coffee is
our coffee brand and when you go to
cw.com and purchase our coffee you are
supporting our show and getting the best
cup of coffee you'll ever have my
personal favorite is Appalachian kns but
it's a close tie with rise withth
Roberto Jr and I'll be totally honest
rise with Roberto Jr sells the most but
I'm pretty sure it's just because it's a
picture of the late and great Roberto Jr
on the bag we've got a different a bunch
of different blends and varieties we
also have K Cups we have ground we have
whole bean and of course the rise with
Roberto Jr Halloween special limited
edition medium roast will be coming out
soon you can join the Casper coffee club
uh we're sponsoring ourselves we're
working on the coffee shop should be
open in a couple months I know it's
delayed delayed delayed but uh if you go
to casper.com and buy from us you are
supporting the work we do but don't
forget to head over to
timcast.net
URL posted on every platform if you
really do want to help out joining us
tonight to talk about this and a whole
lot more is Max Blumenthal how's it
going it's going do good who are you
first of all thank you for the malort
yes uh I cannot believe that Max came in
and I said we have water we have we have
uh you know some whiskey and you can
have whatever you want I most people
don't drink these days and he went oh
I'll have the malort and I was like what
so for those that don't know malort is a
it's a joke in Chicago it is like
considered to be not good we're about to
we're just about to like reveal the
greatest secret right now cuz it's it's
dope I mean you like it I got hooked on
it my most of my family is from Chicago
and I just got hooked on it out there
it's made out of wormwood it's like it's
like bathtub prohibition style liquor
and it's a very acquired taste and so
yeah I was really it was really a
privilege to try that um I am the editor
founder of the gry zone.com we're an
independent website because you really
can't say anywhere outside of
Independent Media these days uh most of
the people I work with all of them can't
work in media and we focus mostly on
issues of Empire uh foreign policy we
try to touch the third rail say what
other people say say what isn't being
said um and I think our work really
speaks for itself and we try to focus on
reporting investigative journalism and
not you know striding commentary we do
lots of video work we do a stream every
week I've written four books I've done
two books on Israel Palestine wow um
Goliath and the 51-day war where I
covered the is the war in Gaza in 2014
which lasted for 51 days and I've done a
documentary about that called killing
Gaza which is free on YouTube um you can
find it at the greyzone YouTube channel
um I directed it um Dan Cohen did a lot
of filming for it and um we I mean Dan
interviewed fighters from these Gaza
factions about why they fight uh we
interviewed people who have
been who um just we showed the whole
spectrum of life in the Gaza Strip Under
Siege and so you know from that
experience that I've had I am not
surprised at all by what's happening
right now I'm not shocked um as
upsetting as it is to watch I'm not
shocked at all so what you're saying is
you're totally partisan no one contr no
I'm just kidding well I'm I'm I I I'm
transparent and I think that's what
people like is they know where you're
coming from well I think it'll be it'll
be interesting to to uh I'm biased but I
I mean we need if we we wouldn't have
got anywhere at the gray Zone if we
weren't ual um but I obviously have a
bias and that will come out in the next
three hours I think it'll be I think
it'll be great so uh thanks for coming
thanks this be fun right on we got Phil
leonti hanging out hello everybody my
name is Phil leonti very failed uh
musician vocalist for All That Remains
anti-communist and counterrevolutionary
guys Ian cross and I've had a powerful
24 hours I I prayed to Jesus for the
first time my life last night uh oh
actually no last night uh was the second
time I prayed to Jesus last night I said
Jesus what should I do and he said go
surfing
and I was like but I knew what he meant
it was like get healthy go out on the
water get away from all the the
radiation like get find peace with
yourself Ian got love bombed yeah and
then the comments are like thousands of
people like finally you understand what
it sounds like what his voice sounds
like and it's like I get it I I
appreciate it yes but I also prayed to
Muhammad and I said what I said please
help me and he said it was this
visualization of a knife like his anger
was palpable so I started listening to
the Quran to understand how he thinks so
that maybe I can have a more clear
prayer Union with him well you know
quite powerful take your journey and
also it's interesting that uh in Gaza
Palestine they had the 51-day war
because I want to make Palestine the
51st American state whoa I think this is
the solution we're just here to offend
everybody
with I want to make life good good for
those people I want to make it a
high-tech place where people can Thrive
and communicate with their neighbors and
live in peace we can have trade unions
all and it can be Islamic in nature
it'll be wonderful I think I think Ian's
probably just being a little a little
hyper
I think it's fair to say no matter who
you are we want peace in the Middle East
we want peace in the world but uh we'll
get into it we got Serge here yeah man
uh you don't pray to Muhammad but I mean
anyways yeah Serge uh surge. goov today
filling in for surge.com uh at least the
way I'm you can tell by the nice the
nice do anyways yeah let's get into it
Tim all right here's the big story this
is from Fox News they say at least 40
babies some beheaded found by is uh
Israel soldiers in Hamas attacked
Village IDF Major General itai verv
described the scene in kafar Aza as a
massacre Israel's military discovered
unspeakable Horrors in an Israeli
community that was attacked by Hamas on
Saturday including dozens of dead babies
some with their heads chopped off
Israeli media reported according to
local Israeli Outlet I24 news IDF
soldiers moved into kafar Aza one of the
communities Hamas terrorists invaded
early Saturday morning and discovered
about 40 dead babies some decapitated
now they say several times before the
article gets started the IDF were
removing the bodies of victims found in
the area when they found the children's
remains Israeli soldiers are attempting
to use bones to identify the victims
according to the report it's not a war
it's not a battlefield you see the
babies the mother the father in their
bedrooms in their protection rooms and
how the terrorists killed them IDF Major
General itai veru said describing the
scene I24 reported it's a massacre now
immediately A lot of people brought up
uh the Nira testimony which is a young
woman Nira alabah in the early 90s in
1990 early 90s who had stated that
saddam's forces were pulling babies out
of incubators and leaving them to die so
the news is obviously shocking and the
first thing I'm just going to say as we
get into this subject matter is look man
this is such a heated issue there are
there's people uh tweeting out photos
and videos they're saying uh uh the the
attacks it's pure evil don't support
this you got tweets from people like Ben
chapiro saying there's a big difference
between is Israel trying to prevent
civilian deaths and Hamas targeting
civilians so obviously this is extremely
heated that being said I remain
skeptical on stories like this there are
a lot of videos I'm seeing shared I
can't prove these videos are what people
say they are there are some videos that
are easily discernible like yes there's
there's paratroopers coming in some of
these are clearly not from uh they're
not uh what people will do is they'll
take videos from other conflicts and
then they'll caption them and put them
as if it was now to shock you or
whatever
some of the videos we've seen are are
are clear and plain as day uh and I
think the reporting speak for itself but
then there are more shocking stories
like this there are videos that start
right in the middle of something
egregious happening that we don't know
where they come from so I just hope
everybody keeps a level head to the best
of their abilities we can try and figure
out what's true and what isn't but I'm
curious what all of you guys think about
this latest reporting because this is
look the the idea that babies are are
beheaded is is international casses
belly I mean it is the US sending a
strike group a carrier group this is we
rally our allies and say these terrorist
groups Must Be Stopped that's why I have
fears about what what these stories uh
mean I the first thing I you know heard
or the first thing that I thought when I
heard it was obviously the uh the
stories that led to the first Iraq war
um the that's the N testimony yeah so I
mean that was the first thing I thought
of and I mean there's plenty of actual
evidence of horrible things happening
when the the Palestinians actually you
know launched the attack I think it was
like 1500 actual Fighters they said
actually went into Palestine there into
is you mean yeah I'm sorry into into
Israel um there's plenty of evidence
that they killed innocent people there's
plenty of evidence that they you know
carried out what amounts to a terror
attack it's not a military operation
there's plenty of evidence so there are
videos you don't want to watch
absolutely and and I don't so I don't
need to I don't need to believe that
they were cutting off baby's heads to
condemn
the attack on Israel so you know I if if
it turns out that it happened I'm not
shocked I mean I was alive when Isis
when when the the the uh the Islamic
State was in existence and the and I saw
videos of them cutting off people's
heads and doing terrible things I
remember 9/11 you know that you don't
need to have this particular thing to be
real to be like okay terrorists do
really horrible horrible things with the
intent of terrorizing people I'm curious
what you think Max yeah I I would be
shocked first of all because Hamas is
mortally opposed to Isis and salafi
elements they've actually battled them
in the streets in Rafa before uh they
consider them a threat to their
stability and is Israeli intelligence
actually has worked with salafi elements
in Gaza to destabilize Hamas just as
Israeli intelligence supported Hamas to
destabilize the PLO when it controlled
Gaza in the 1980s so I would be shocked
if they employed something like this the
only source so far on this story is one
Israeli soldier uh who's a very
interesting character we've traced his
identity at the gry zone and it comes
through a state sponsored Israeli media
organization as he pointed out I24 the
reporter Nicole sedc who just went to
kafar oza and said I'm hearing that
babies were beheaded then the Israeli
foreign Ministry goes and blasts it out
40 babies beheaded why because the US
bombed the crap out of Isis in ra that
we destroyed half of the city of rqa and
that's what Israel wants us to do to
Iran they want us to see Hamas as Isis
and then to get involved in their
regional conflict so they're pushing
this story The Source is a Israeli
soldier named davidi benzion who is a
settler leader he's from one of the
fanatical wings of Israeli politics and
he uh you know he's a reservist he's
serving in the military but he got in
trouble earlier this year because he
called for an entire Palestinian Village
to to be wiped off the map next to his
illegal settlement in the West Bank and
he's the guy go that she's interviewing
as her credible witness I don't trust it
and as you said Israel has enough to go
on right now to try to portray itself
even though it's the occupier and
besieger of the Gaza Strip according to
international law to portray itself as a
victim why do they need to do this it's
because it's because they're trying to
draw the US in I agree with that for
sure that because because that's why
everybody immediately brings up the near
testimony what will shock a Americans to
the most extreme degree to justify us
involvement you should break that down
though like the near testimony yeah I
mean I I can I can break it down we have
the Wikipedia pulled up uh false
testimony given to the United States
Congress Congressional human rights
caucus October 10th 1990 by a
15-year-old girl who was publicly
identified by the time by her first name
naira the testimony was widely
publicized and was cited numerous times
by US senators and George HW Bush in
their rational to to support Kuwait in
the Gulf War in 1992 it was revealed n
uh uh nira's last name name was El saah
and that she was the daughter of sa Al
Sabah the Kuwaiti ambassador to the US
furthermore it was revealed that a
testimony was organized as part of the
citizens for a free Kuwait public
relations Campaign which was run by the
American public relations firm Hill and
Nolton for the Kuwaiti government
following this alah's testimony has
become regarded as a classic example of
modern atrocity propaganda so it is it
it is false testimony uh her story
initially was even corroborated by
Amnesty International so this is crazy I
mean I'm a little kid I'm four years old
when this stuff's going down actually
what what month was it it was October so
I was yeah I was the story was that they
were stabbing babies in incubators with
bayonets and throwing them on the ground
so that way they could take the
incubators back to Iraq from Kuwait that
was the that was the story like and I
mean I was 15 when I heard it or
whatever so you know what the hell did I
know but I was like oh that's so
terrible but now looking back obviously
it's like it especially today with the
the way that that we have the ability to
communicate and produce fake videos and
have videos that don't have any context
with them you have to be really careful
you know look man uh do I think it's
possible that some babies were killed
yes absolutely uh if if if they're if
they're coming into a Kuts and they're
shooting yeah there's Crossfire I see
kids killed in Chicago right it's and
then you're in an active conflict Zone
likely going to happen I think it's
possible that uh uh like the most
reasonable and rational thing that could
that that I would say highest
probability in terms of this being
truthful is that you know a couple
babies died one had its man this is such
horrible thing to say but SE severely
injured to the point of decapitation and
then someone passes it along and it
purple monkey dishwashers itself
telephones itself into 40 babies killed
beheaded in a more extreme version of
the story but now it serves a political
purpose so it escalates to a point where
Fox News is reporting it headline as
though it's you know proven the
challenging thing is what do you need
how do you prove it what do you like
what do you do if this is if this is
true if they're not lying well there's
another purpose to it which is to
deflect from the obviously true real
videos of babies being killed by Israeli
air strikes all across the Gaza Strip
when I was in Gaza in 2014 I went to Han
Yunis which is in the Southeast uh had
been completely destroyed at its eastern
Edge by the Israeli military and the
casualties were so intense that the
hospital started filling up in Khan
yunas and I went to a small hospital and
talked to the head of the hospital and
he showed me photos and I've these
photos are on my Twitter page from the
time all real he had to bring in from
local shops ice cream coolers to store
dead babies in because the mortuaries
had run out of space and now we see
Israel attacking the hospital in banoon
in the north is completely out of
commission uh all of these hospitals are
coming under attack so babies are are
dying in the Gaza Strip there's video
right now Jackson Hinkle just tweeted a
video of a father carrying his baby out
of the rubble there's another video on
times of Gaza a local publication of a
father putting his bit infant daughter
to sleep for the last time and they've
completely erased these casualties
they've always been erased and that's
part of what fuels the the violence and
the ruthlessness that we see from these
Fighters is that they want to avenge
what they call their Martyrs and that
fuels what is you know referred to as
the cycle of violence this the
invisibilization of them so you you you
think that some Hamas Fighters they they
target civilians because civilians in
Gaza are targeted well first of all let
let's let's let's let's point out
another thing that's being left out of
the conversation what CNN never showed
this fox never showed this they targeted
military bases primarily military bases
like nahal that are maintaining the
siege of Gaza and they overwhelmed those
bases and humiliated the fourth most
powerful military on the planet with a
Bluewater Navy with nuclear weapons some
of these Fighters were filmed entering
the bases with no shoes on they're using
homemade weapons
AK-47s uh paragliders fishing boats to
get in this is not a powerful Army and
they humiliated them and Israelis
vaunted intelligence services so they
don't want to talk about that and yes
they went in a lot of these kibit Sim
are right next to the bases I've been to
them yeah they they they did like I mean
this is a terorist attack they went to a
music festival and started killing
people so I get what you're saying like
they are definitely the under underdogs
and stuff but like to classify it to try
and point out that it's or to make it to
legitimize it as a as an actual military
operation I think totally glosses over
the fact that they attacked civilians
intentionally they did it was a military
operation and Israel is now attacking
civilians intentionally they're not
targeting targeting Israel has a
doctrine of targeting civilians
intentionally it's called the dahia
doctrine and I can lay out what it is
but they believe that if they attack
civilians and humiliate them they will
overthrow they will eventually rise up
against their government they tested it
against Hezbollah and Lebanon and it
failed it's called and it's and it's
being used against the civilians in the
Gaza Strip they want to lower their
morale so much that they actually turn
but you're still talking about a you're
talking about a retaliation right like
CU like I said again this initially
started and and granted you you I don't
know the the details about about where
they if they attack the uh the military
bases or whatever and I'm not trying to
push back on that but the idea that this
is just a military operation they
specifically went and started killing
people at the festival like I I mean it
has all of the the it reminds me of the
bodon in Paris like it's a terror attack
the point is to like so maybe if you
want to say that the Israelis are
terrorists as well fine like I'm I'm not
here to defend Israel but the idea that
the initial attack was a military
operation or exclusively military uh-uh
they attacked people and they went after
civilians and killed people at a at a
show when when Max I bring this up I
mean my I'm I'm not interjecting because
I want to hear what you have to say
about what were they targeting in terms
of military targets I don't think it
makes sense for Hamas to come in and
just literally only target a music
festival obviously I think it's it's
reasonable that they targeted a wide
bread of of things but uh I do agree
with Phil I mean the problem is the one
of the arguments where hearing is that
they're breaking out of an open air
prison well okay absolutely I mean uh I
I I know people who have are the
families of those in Palestine those who
have come from Gaza and absolutely have
heard these arguments but to then see
them going to music F like a music
festival and laughing about it you know
and and and grabbing people and throwing
them on the ground we I mean I suppose
the argument is the videos are all fake
or something but there's videos of the
guys walking up to cars and just
shooting regular people like just in
their cars who have no idea what's going
on what's that Israeli doctrine of
targeting civilians called deia Doctrine
and they also if you could if you look
up Israel in mowing the lawn that's a
common term that the Israeli military
uses that ain't just the Israeli
military blood makes the grass gr homie
no no but we but I I I brought this up
before when uh um I think I brought this
up when I was on pbd on Saturday when
this all went down back when protective
Edge happened in 2014 I I did not cover
uh this stuff mine mine was civil unrest
not Civil War not not war but uh
speaking with many of the journalists
who had covered the region both in
Israel and in Palestine and these guys I
got to tell you if you met them you'd be
like they're they're middle of the road
milk toast fencor types they they refer
to it as mowing the lawn they say Israel
every a couple of years will decimate
parts of Gaza to reduce you know uh uh
as they described it their military
capabilities but I'm curious what you
know if you want to elaborate on that
yeah I mean there's there there's so
many issues on the table I mean to the
music festival which is like the the
most you know Grizzly thing one of the
most Grizzly things we've seen prior to
Israel leveling entire neighborhoods in
Gaza City including neighborhoods I
stayed in where many people actually are
not friendly to Hamas um they're holding
an EDM mly field Music Festival on the
the drugs that they that they're on are
do not matter it doesn't matter that
they're doing okay doesn't matter what
drugs they're on you're right what
matters is they're holding a music
festival on the border of a caged in
ghetto where people are have very little
water they bathe in saltwater in Gaza
I've done it they bathe in saltwater
they have two to three hours of
electricity and they're doing this right
there right next to a military base and
what appears to have happened is a
military base was targeted these this
this music festival became a target of
opportunity which is you know
unfortunate and maybe gut-wrenching
there's no way to justify it and here's
what the objective of these fighter one
of the main objectives which is not
really discussed properly in our media
and it doesn't matter if you support
Israel or Palestine here you have to
acknowledge this objective it's to get
as many Israeli citizens into the hands
of the authorities in Gaza to negotiate
because Israel is holding thousands and
thousands of Palestinian captives in its
prison there is one guy named had adad
who died this this may after a three
month three-month hunger strike so
you're you just said that you said the
goal is to kidnap SP negotiations and
change the Strategic by kidnapping and
bringing them back to Gaza that's
kidnapping that's terrorist activity
that isra I've watched Israel kidna
children
from occupied Villages no it's not it's
not about this is not about right or
wrong it's about not being not seeing
this in a stupid emotional way I'm not
saying you're being stupid or emotional
but we are being cultivated in this
country to be stupid and emotional by
not trying to understand why this attack
took place gilad Shalit was an Israeli
soldier who is captured out of his tank
in 2011 by fighters from Gaza actually
not affiliated with Hamas and Israel was
forced to exchange over 1,000
Palestinian prisoners captives in the
mind of Palestinians for this one
soldier so now they have let's say a 100
captives they do not want them to die in
Gaza because this is the only bargaining
chip they've had after Palestinians have
had every single diplomatic Channel
blocked to them and they are even
they've even had food channels blocked
to them people people want us to take
the most emotional approach to this
they're killing civilians and stuff I
think I think you know that's typically
my view it's bad that they're doing that
I agree with Phil but I do think it's
absolutely Fair uh to step back and say
why are they doing it how do they view
it and and to do that involves some very
ruthless kidnapp exactly kidnapping
civilians which they've explicitly said
they will now execute unless Israel
takes spe specific specific actions like
no more bombings the return of other War
they said warn before bombing because
Israel's been bringing roofs down on the
heads of entire families a family of 19
was killed in in jabali a refugee camp
that's what they said they didn't the
but the Palestinians didn't warn the
Israelis that they were coming to the
festival right they didn't warn the
Israel they wereing if the festival was
the
target they weren't warning they weren't
warning people they weren't warning the
Israelis that they were coming so you're
pointing out that the Israelis do warn
the Palestinians like hey this location
we are going to blow it up yeah like I
do I I correct correctly if I'm wrong I
think uh uh the alasan brigades warned
ashalon that they were going to be
firing a bunch of rockets ashalon I
think yes they did they should these
areas are now mostly evacuated but uh
you know I've done interviews in Gaza
just like we're doing now although maybe
without the malort
and I went up in Palestine Tower to do
an interview in the middle of Gaza City
I walked up nine flights of stairs
because the electricity was off
everything's running on generators there
um and did some interviews few years
later Israel drops a warning flare on
the roof of that media tower where all
the journalists work and operate I've
also edited videos from there with some
really nice Palestinian journalists just
cool people you would all like to hang
out with who would love to leave their
little strip of land and can't anyway
and then Israel brings the whole Tower
down there's video of it so it's okay
they warn it but why are they bringing
down residential and office Towers while
everyone is silent and allegedly because
there's
Hamas that building I mean well you
asked the reason so that's the reason
they say at least so well this this this
is the challenge for those that are not
involved right I I'm I'm anti-war I
think us involvement in in 99% of things
is they lies I mean I grew up on this
stuff right all all the lies to get us
to what's put military basis surrounding
Iran uh John Bolton saying by this time
next year we'll be celebrating inan it's
it's bloodlust so when I look at
something like Israel the challenge for
me is I'm not nearly as involved as you
and I'm not nearly as zealous as many of
like the neoconservatives and the more
conservative base so when Rockets come
flying from uh uh from Gaza and start
blowing up over Tel Aviv I this was huge
right this was like 2014 when the
Rockets first started reaching Tel Aviv
was that because I remember uh I had a
friend in Tel Aviv I was there at that
time yeah mess messaged me freaking out
on Facebook that exploded over her house
and this has never happened before and
she does know what to do and and I'm
like man this is horror it's horror it's
War it's terrifying how do we stop this
and so what ends up happening is every
time I've engaged with it again not an
expert on this stuff I mean I prob might
know a little bit more than the average
person but it's like I appreciate your
perspective I'm glad you're here to tell
us about this stuff too uh because I
think only talking to people who are on
the more Pro isal side is going to leave
us you know blind to the arguments from
the other side but I hear Israel they're
they're they're using hospitals and
schools and civilian areas to launch
rockets from knowing that it will make
it extremely difficult for Israel to
stop the rocket fire into civilian areas
then I hear the same thing but a media
tower was taken down for what purpose
why is Israel targeting this and every
time I hear this my Med Communications I
fall right back to This Is War and in in
war the rule there's no rules rules are
for in my it's like this idea of war
crimes I always find so silly like
obviously we think some things are so
egregious that even in war they're a
crime but yo the people who win those
Wars don't care what you think because
you're gone and so when I look at what's
going on in Israel and Palestine I know
that you've got two factions that are
going to use whatever arguments whatever
whatever psychological warfare whatever
physical Warfare they can to try and win
this and I know that there probably is a
right a right side and someone's telling
the truth and I know for a fact there's
an objective truth and and lies to
what's going on I don't know how to
navigate that well just two points on
that I mean there's this issue of human
Shields like Biden said Palestinians or
human Shields that's a way of basically
saying there are no civilians there at
all and the Gaza Strip is one of the
most densely populated places on million
people there's like it's two million
people jamm why are they there by the
way that most of them are refugees and
they have to be there because they're
not Jewish they can't go back to the
land of their families pre
pre-1948 they keep having kids they're
being warehoused there they're Surplus
Humanity so it's like the logic of a
prison and so everybody there is a human
shield but there was a place I I like to
eat because was real cheap in in Tel
Aviv that was right next to the um
defense Ministry called hakira and the
all the generals would be in there the
intelligence Chiefs good Mediterranean
food are they human Shields is is that
is building this giant Tower in the
middle of a residential area in Tel Aviv
are they making those people human
Shields if that gets hit by Hezbollah
and people die nearby were they being
used by Israel as human Shields no one
will say that because the logic is so
discriminatory towards Palestinians no
one will consider consider their
position and then the other point I
wanted to make is just about the use of
violence in this conflict by
Palestinians who have tried everything I
mean I don't know if you know about what
the the great March of return was was
sanctioned by Hamas but it was a
Grassroots initiative in Gaza to just
March without weapons like guns to the
wall that surrounds them and they were
shot one by one in the legs many of them
were killed uh journalists were killed
covering it it was a complete blood bath
and that's when the society said you
know what we can't win with this tactic
of you know walking to the fence and
just asking them to let us in they don't
want us that's that's and and so and
everyone and and you know no one
everyone ignored that and now they're
paying attention to the violence in Gaza
used to have 9,000 settlers in it 9,000
settlers who took like 30 to 40% of the
water in a place of 1.5 million people
why did those settlers leave it was
because of the second intifa it was
because of the violence that was applied
and much more gruesome violence in many
ways than we're seeing now because this
was the time of suicide bombings um
people willing to die because they were
so desperate blowing themselves up in
order to kill because they had no
weapons at that point now the the
factions in Gaza actually have reverse
engineered Israel's military and they
have weapons so they don't need to do
suicide bombing so Gaza did that they
got too Hamas did that then what is the
West Bank right now it's controlled by
the Palestinian Authority which has
funded partly through the EU and state
department they don't resist Israel in
fact they arrest Palestinians on behalf
of Israel and what do Palestinians have
there in many ways they have the same
prison style situation as they have in
Gaza but with settlers all around them
so what does that tell Palestinians it
tells them the only way to get this off
our back is through violence is are
there Palestinians who live in Israel
yes in like Tel Aviv and all that are
they uh they well they live in mostly in
an area South called Jaffa or yafa but I
mean like somebody who is of Palestinian
they're 1.5 million Palestinian citizens
of Israel and they're said to have equal
rights but there are discriminatory laws
on the books yeah MOS right there's like
400 mosques within Israel right yeah I
mean the mosques op um operate I mean
there's pressure on them to like shut
off the mine at night and you know
there's all kinds of like personal like
individual conflicts or cultural
conflicts taking place but yes there are
Palestinian citizens what's the
solution I mean it's like the
generational question that nobody has
the answer to offer Palestine to become
the 51st state of the UN States come on
let's let's let's I'm getting 100%
serious okay but that's that's not
that's not where is see Palestine is not
a state it can be and no Hawaii Hawaii
can be a
state is will never let them be a
country no we we work with Israel to
make it a peaceful place they either
that or get Anil what other choice I I
I'm interested in asking M ma Max this
question because of your extensive
coverage of it your views on on the
conflict yeah and uh right now I think
it's fair to say every single person
wants peace there's clearly a divide
though and it's that Israel's view of
peace is very different from Palestinian
view of peace and then say our view of
peace right middle of the road anti-war
Americans who are like why are we
involved in this and how do we make it
stop or do we do nothing at all and stay
completely out of it because like what
is what is
this what what what how do we if if you
know if if Hamas is like we're going to
go take civilians because they're
bargaining chips for us you've now got a
story where I'm like bro I'm 37 this
conflict's been going on a lot longer
than I've been alive and all I know is I
watch a video of people storming a music
festival killing and kidnapping people
all I see that's bad we want to stop I
see three ways for this to end either
it's the total obliteration and
annihilation of 2 million Palestinians
or it's they refugee and they flee the
land and they come here to the United
States or somewhere else or they are
absorbed into another Nation I I those
are three solutions that Israeli
leadership is kind of putting forward
because they cannot exist with
Palestinians in their midst and like EG
Egypt doesn't want to take them and and
Jordan was doesn't want to take them and
Lebanon doesn't want no one wants to
take yet why won't Egypt open up Rafa
and let them come because it's
politically F to have the Palestinian
problem the F the fight with it between
the the Arabs and the Jews that's
politically useful the Jordan is
politically useful to Lebanon it's
politically useful to Egypt it's for the
same reason that many Americans don't
want Hondurans or Mexicans coming across
the border the Egyptians look down on
Palestinians and they consider them a
burden on a society with 90 million
people with a very weak State uh where
there's a lot of poverty um and Rafa the
Rafa Crossing between Gaza and Israel
was bombed today uh with many people who
are dual Nationals trying to get out as
Netanyahu and the Israeli leadership are
saying leave Gaza and we won't bomb you
but they have nowhere to go um but you
know on this issue of the solution I
mean we're entering a very dangerous
phase and we're looking at the Holy Land
right now so this does affect us all if
this conflict moves from a political
conflict which it always has been it's
not about the Bible it's about the
colonization of the land of Palestine
and people trying to get their land and
right back and and and then another
group of people trying to have a state
run along ethn religious lines as a
Jewish state if it moves into a
religious conflict we're all screwed and
it's going there this operation waged by
Hamas and um Palestinian Islamic Jihad
was called al- AA flood it's about the
al- AXA mosque and what's been going on
there is that the security minister of
Israel who's the biggest Fanatic in
Israeli Society his name is idar benir
he's LED literal riots against
Palestinian shops he's so extreme the
Israeli military would not allow him in
he's been convicted in Israeli courts of
terrorism he is now the security
minister because Benjamin Netanyahu
needs him and his small party in order
to maintain his Coalition he has been
leading groups up to the aloa compound
of uh Jewish extremists who try to break
in there into the third holiest site in
Islam in a direct provocation and what
they want to do is blow up the aloa
compound and bring back the third Jewish
temple and they belong to a movement
called the temple movement which sees
the Jewish prayer that takes place at
the Western Wall as phony as fake what
they think the original prayer that took
place there was the mass slaughtering of
sheep continuously and they want to do
that there so this is these are kind of
elements that are provoking one another
and leading us into a religious conflict
that would be disastrous we were talking
real quick doesn't Al in Arabic meanthe
yeah kind of yeah I just wanted to point
that out because it's funny because we
sayth Al Whatever like we say thethe I
you know I just thought it was
interesting I'll we were talking I I I
disagree about the context the modern
context being the actual driver we were
talking earlier today uh before the show
about the the actual driver I it is
biblical it goes all the way back to to
Genesis the between the feud between
Ishmael and Isaac or the the the
the fact that the story says that Isaac
was God's CH was was chosen by God and
Ishmael is the father of the Arabs
Isaac's the father of the Jews this is
this this is like the Hatfield and McCoy
Feud on steroids it goes back thousands
and thousands and thousand 3,000 years
or whatever I don't know how far back
but people that put it into a modern
context I understand that like because
there are things that inflame the
tensions but the tensions go far beyond
just you know it it's it's deeper than
Islam yeah and that's the thing that
most Americans don't realize Americans
think that it's about a religion and
it's not it's an ethnic Feud that goes
far deeper than than a religion I think
a lot of the tension comes from that but
the violence is coming from the
colonization uh sure it's it's you can
always do a video chat and get past your
hatred of each other but if if you're
going to die you have a choice some
people can I know I know this this is
particularly contentious so yes ladies
and gentlemen
we we I I I do want to bring on I'd love
to bring on someone who a journalist who
has covered the Israeli perspective not
that I think that you necessarily don't
but you do have your biases I wrote a
book about the Israeli perspective it's
called Goliath and I lived in Jerusalem
in one of the most Jewish areas for
almost a year just trying to absorb that
that's fair but I'm je and I'm Jewish
myself and I came to this understanding
by first going on the birthright Israel
trip which is a free trip for Jews uh it
was then 18 to 25 and you know it's
basically like the best sex vacation
ever uh like they want you to mate they
want Jews to have relationships because
you know we're not getting you know we
don't pratie so they're encouraging you
to have sex with Israeli soldiers it's a
big party but I got really really into
the situation there and it was right at
the dawn of the second in tiata and it
affected me in a way that they didn't
want it to I mean they did propagandize
us so for there there are obviously a
lot of people who we got some chats
where they're saying it's great you're a
real journalist covering this cuz you
know but then there are other people
saying that you're you're a joke and
you're wrong about this stuff but I do
want to point out the the the seemingly
contradictory uh statement you made
earlier I I say seemingly in that the
people's view of tribal politics uh you
you had praised for Donald Trump's uh
peace efforts before the show I don't
know if you want to depending on which
peace efforts talking for sure but we're
talking about North Korea and South
Korea and you were saying like you know
I won't speak for yous in the Bloods
yeah yeah yeah I mean a one point to you
real quick before I get into that um if
Christians should be paying special
attention to this conflict because the
Christians who live in Bethlehem they
have nothing to do with Hamas they're
not represented by any of these factions
but they are affected by occupation and
they are being forced out of their lands
where they are carrying the tradition of
the disciples uh the Anastos family who
I know had a the wall the separation
wall built entirely around their home
and shop and that was the end of their
existence there they are directly
descended from the disciples so this
isn't just about Jews and Muslims and by
the way Jews and Muslims resisted the
Crusaders in Jerusalem we haven't always
been enemies but to your point about
Trump uh no you wanted to say something
well just the the I wanted to point out
that the the way you've characterized
this you've you've called you've you've
called Jews terrorists multiple times
and every time that anyone T and then I
talk about the the fact that the
operation was a ter Terror operation you
push back on it so I I understand that
you have a a perspective and it's
totally cool I'm not trying to I'm not
trying to to say you're wrong for having
an opinion or having having a
perspective but I do want to point out
you you are characterizing the Israelis
as Jews and you talk about how farri
right and and how bloodthirsty they are
and the terror attack you you've been
pushing back on and saying well it's not
a terror attack and that and Etc so I
mean I just wanted to call attention to
it it it is not just that Jews are
terrorists or that the uh Palestinians
are terrorists this particular issue
this particular flare up or whatever is
because of a terrorist attack but it's
not that one side or the other are the
bad guys and the good guys I at least I
don't see it that way it's well it's for
me it's about Justice and Injustice one
side is much more powerful than the
other and is has been abusing them
historically but Israel to me does not
represent Judaism to me that's an not
that's an anti-semitic point of view and
actually anti-semites try to implicate
all Jews by by invoking Israel's crimes
I see Israel as embracing the philosophy
of Zionism and if you go to Brooklyn and
you see all those Ultra Orthodox Jews
from the satmar clan they're not
zionists in many ways they're
anti-zionist so all Jews are not
zionists back to Trump the I yes I I
mean as we were saying before the show I
mean I stood and cheered when he crossed
the DMV DMZ into North Korea I never
thought I would see an American
president do that and in some in so in
so many ways um Trump going off script
was the greatest thing about the Trump
era I never thought American president
would do that admitting the weapons
deals of Saudi Arabia and all that stuff
the oil fields in Syria it's it was it's
like not good things but it's like he's
saying it yeah even with the bad things
he lifted the mask on American Empire
because he wasn't trying to be elegant
about it he just told the truth about
what we are uh with with with Israel
though I don't know if you remember but
it was like in 2015 he REM went to the
Republican Jewish Coalition and he said
like I'm a landlord a lot of you guys
are landlords we need to make a deal
with Israel Palestine and the they
called him an anti-semite for saying
that he's like he's calling Jews
landlords who are deal
makers and then he changed and Jared
Kushner came in the equation his
son-in-law I mean just imagine if
Trump's son-in-law was paltin what what
do you think about the Abraham Accords
well the Abraham Accords are a real
reason why this happened why uh these
attacks took place because the whole
point of the Abraham Accords was to go
over over the heads of the Palestinians
put that whole issue in the ice box
forever let them stay in their cages or
wherever maybe give them a few crumbs
and then Israel will make peace with the
monarchies who have all the money and
all of the um you know Sovereign wealth
funds and Jared Kushner is directly
overseeing that there's going to be more
Trump Towers in Dubai and meanwhile
Trump goes and assassinates kasum Solani
second most powerful figure prestigious
figure in Iran who heads the IR R GC
which has a relationship with the
factions in Gaza as well as Lebanon I
mean he was setting the stage for all
this so the Abraham Accords and the
normalization with Saudi Arabia between
Israel and Saudi Arabia the the aloa
flood operation declared by Hamas was
explicitly designed to undermine that
like they openly said it then what I I
guess the the issue
is everything leads to chaos everything
leads to conflict well everything leads
back to Jerusalem in in the Middle East
and the Palestinians will not allow
themselves the rest of the region
especially these monarchs who don't
answer to anybody except their own
internal Clan they will not allow
themselves to be ignored what would
happen if the security fencing the
barriers around the Gaza Strip were all
removed and all the people of pal
Palestine were granted free movement
what would happen well it would
certainly reduce the drive to violence
and revenge over time but there would no
longer what what would they be within
what we call Israel and this goes to the
whole logic of Zionism in order to have
a Jewish State you have to have a
demographic majority of Jews within a
certain territory although Israel has no
internationally recognized borders the
US has a border like you all support def
defending the border Israel doesn't
actually have a border it just has areas
that it declares Israel and then it says
we have a majority of Jews we are the
Jewish state so the areas outside AR the
borders created by all the around it
though well Palestinians don't have a
country Gaza is not a country it's a
human Warehouse because they're not Jews
but Jordan and Egypt and Lebanon they
all have borders yeah so that that's
what declares itself a democracy while
violently demographically engineering a
demog a majority of a specific ethn
religious group so that would be like
the US saying we are a white Christian
Nation we're not deporting the migrants
because they're not legal citizens we're
deporting them because they're not white
Christians that is the problem that's
why Gaza is there and has to perpetually
be there but I mean they're having kids
right the population's growing yeah so
it it doesn't I mean Israel could cut
food off and stop population growth they
could do they just cut off electricity
gas and water I mean after Hamas came in
and killed a bunch of civilians and you
know shot up a bunch of you know houses
and stuff I mean so you know I look at
it and I'm like if Hamas perhaps you can
argue that is a rough Edge scalpel in
their attacks which results in it it
backs fire backfires on them
tremendously uh you know I want to see
peace I don't I don't like the stories
that you know I hear from you about
what's going on in Gaza but all I see
with everything they've just done is
they've exacerbated the problem
t uh why why would they do this they
have no from their point of view there's
no other diplomatic path to getting out
of the siege and The Siege was becoming
too comfortable for Israel they had
Israel's always going to be in a
comfortable situation as long as the
Palestinians don't do anything firing
Rockets what do they gain by firing
Rockets well I mean in in each in each
conflict the more Rockets I mean this is
not my justification I've been under
those Rockets too it's not pleasant it's
not as bad as being under the Israeli
missiles that I've been under which is
absolutely horrifying with a drone over
your head all night and you wake up and
houses are blown up around you but it's
still scary the point is they get
concessions and it's the only way and
the only time that Israel has ever given
them any concessions whether it's more
work all I hear Terror works all I hear
you saying is Terrorism works or let's
let's look at it from thisp let's make
the other hypothetical State Terror
works as well we're the masters of it
from from the perspective uh from from
your perspective you could make the
argument that Israel lets them fire the
Rockets to justify the the the the
expansion of control over the Gaza Strip
and that you're saying it works maybe
they want it to work they want Hamas to
constantly attack civilians so they can
go to the international stage they can
go to the United States they can go to
foreign countries and say see this is
why we need money and this is why we're
justified in controlling the things that
we control having the Iron Dome I I kind
of view it like like look like right now
for the average American who has no idea
about what this conflict is rooted in
all they know is that civilians were
massacred can you tell me it it is uh go
ahead tell me about the Bal for
declaration unless you want to keep
going this is about the Inception of the
idea of the British mandate for
Palestine we talked about last night
basically the end of World War I the
Arabs were fighting with the Ottomans
the the Germans and the austrians and
they were Des they were winning the war
so the British and the French
manipulated the Arabs and they were like
if you betray the Ottoman Empire we'll
give you this land we call Palestine
after the war so the Arabs were like
sweet they betrayed the Ottomans the
French and the British won the war and
then they went back on their deal with
this secret declaration the Bal for
declaration can you take me from there
and talk me through uh after we we cover
where where you were at uh Tim uh which
the gist of it being to the average
person around the world who doesn't
follow this stuff yeah Hamas just
committed a major Act of Terror killing
civilians right well the the the yeah
but that's because they're being
propagandized by corporate media which
is telling them this is unprovoked I
mean just look up how many times but
provocation is is IMM material I mean
like for for me when I cover this
context isn't material but the reason
the reason that they did it was because
otherwise they're consolidating
permanent Siege in the Gaza Strip and
yes it's it's a fact as you pointed out
that Israel initially supported a Hamas
actually the mosad funneled money as
Robert Fisk reported into hamas's
coffers in the 1980s because they wanted
to destroy the PLO which was secular
more socialist oriented and they saw
them as the greater threat Israel
allowed Hamas free movement around the
Gaza Strip when Israel internally
controlled the Gaza Strip but we're ENT
we're we're entering a new era era in
World Rel in international relations a
multi-polar era where the United States
doesn't matter as much and so while we
this this is kind of a a bonanza for
Israel to be able to show these images
of a music festival being attacked and
so on but the United States doesn't
matter as much in the region and Iran is
emerging as a regional power so I think
the calculous on the ground is changing
a little bit and it's moving more in
favor of the Palestinians as long as and
and and I think that is another factor
in why this took place um on the B the
balfor Declaration I mean you're you're
talking about the earliest stages of the
colonial Powers handing over the land of
Palestine to those they saw as a more
powerful force and a lot of it was
motivated actually by anti-Semitism I
mean balfor didn't have kind things to
say about Jews in the UK and so he
thought that if we actually displace our
are what he saw as a Jewish Problem onto
the backs of an indigenous population
just get our Jews out of England and put
them there it's going to be a good deal
for us and they'll be our allies
eventually and maybe we can use them to
control the Suez Canal perpetually if we
lose control of it um there uh the the
the English anti-semites were not the
only anti-semites in history to see
Zionist colonization as a positive thing
uh the large lest export market for the
Zionist colonies in 1930s and pre-state
1940s Palestine was Germany and the
Zionist movement the labor Wing the you
know quasi socialist Wing actually Inked
a formal deal with Nazi Germany called
the havara agreement the transfer
agreement anyone can look this up it's
on the books and basically what they
were doing was they were exchanging the
property of Jews in Germany for their
bodies and more Jews means we'll start
to move towards a Jewish majority here
and they'll they'll fight the indigenous
people and then the na Nazi Germany was
saying well we'll get their property and
we need their wealth so it was a very
convenient Arrangement um David Ben
guan's number two his name was himar
loser off you don't have to worry about
the names but he was actually
assassinated when he bragged about this
deal in Tel Aviv so there's been tons of
collaboration with anti-semites in order
to consolidate the colonization of
Palestine now look at this there's this
carrier back group that's sailing into
the region there's so much we can say
about it but what it but but one thing
it says is that first of all
Palestinians have no sovereignty they
cannot call on anyone to support them
militarily and I mean Iran Iran's kind
of supporting the military AR they they
can't come in with a you know their
Iranian fastboats or whatever they they
can't really come in there they can't
get in there let me let me pulp this
story we have this from the AP the US
will send a carrier strike group to the
Eastern Mediterranean in support of
Israel so this news came just the other
day it's on top of what we're hearing
now from CNN that the US is offering
Special Forces as several of the
hostages or some of the hostages taken
are believed to be Americans I was
saying this the other day my concern is
if Americans are captured and some of
these uh one one of the one of the one
of the individuals that's taken hostage
is an IDF soldier who is a dual citizen
American and Israeli which creates all
sorts of questions about should the US
be involved no question the us is going
to use that they're going to say that's
an American citizen despite the fact it
was also an Israeli citizen fighting on
behalf of Israel you know in a conflict
but now with the deployment of a car
carer strike group I'm I'm curious the
The Chance by which the US gets involved
in a direct conflict which is a d
dramatic escalation and and what could
possibly happen do you think the U I
mean look the US is involved this is it
deploying a carrier strike group is
involvement but where where do we see
this
going um has Bola took out an Israeli
Cruiser class ship in 2006 with I think
a French exos set missile that was
smuggled in it was one of their
surprises so they in southern Lebanon
have the capacity to take out ships I
don't think they'd be stupid enough to
do this but you now have us Assets in
there that are just a trigger point for
World War II it would probably be better
if there were fewer us assets in the
area honestly just because the just
because like Max it's it's then you
have in in 2014 I remember uh protective
Edge kicked off and I'm hanging out with
a bunch of journalists and they were
concerned about a very slim possibility
of World War III that actions taken
against Gaza could inight Iran and then
Russia and then China and then you get
you know much like the assassination of
France Ferdinand was not to at that time
when that happened nobody said that
that's it it's World War I like the
world war started no no the
assassination happened it got reported
and then over a long period of time
treaties kick in eventually it's called
the Great War We Now call World War
World War I there was fear that
protective Edge could lead to something
like that but ultimately it didn't it
was 51 days now with this with the us
being more directly involved with the
active war in Eastern Europe which is
very much related to energy Syria the
Syrian conflict and Iraq and a bunch of
other countries and then the fear that
China moves on
Taiwan we could be really knocking on a
legitimate World War III knocking on the
door of yeah I mean I think Syria and a
of ways was kind of a a laboratory or
sort of a a test case for World War III
because you had Russia coming in with
Iran and Hezbollah to stop us and
Western proxy forces who happen to be
aligned with Al-Qaeda and Isis and
Israel was actually supporting Al-Qaeda
and Isis in the Golan it was giving them
weapons it was allowing them to pass in
and out of the Golan actually Moshe ya
Alon who was the Israeli defense
minister at the time this is a headline
I would prefer Islamic State to Iran in
Syria in The Times of Israel you can
look that up um so now now is that
because of the difference between the
Shia and the Sunni Muslims that and that
they are just weaker and they don't want
to fight Israel because in many ways
they're just a creation of the West um I
mean if there is a regional War all
those Al-Qaeda forces in idlib and Syria
that resist that fought the Syrian
government they're not going to be
fighting on
um against Israel and they're kind of
like on Israel's side Al-Qaeda and Isis
I mean just think about that but uh what
could happen here that I think could set
the region on fire is and it's already
happening anyway is if Israel tries to
march on Gaza City uh it would be a
disaster for them they'd lose so many
people there would be thousands and
thousands of casualties inside Gaza it's
not favorable terrain for Israel didn't
uh IDF go on the ground in 2014 yeah and
they did didn't go very well for them
they went into an area called shuay East
of Gaza City and lost something like 40
soldiers including officers they totally
underestimated the alassan brigades the
armed wing of Hamas and they retreated
and then blank it in the whole area with
howitzers and missiles which is why that
if you look at the rubble from 2014 it's
that area I've been there we've filmed
it it's in our film killing Gaza but if
they go all the way to Gaza City and
they're already saw ing it up they've
like destroyed an entire neighborhood in
the center of Gaza City where all the
administrative buildings are all the
cafes the middle class lives if they go
all the way there and they try to bring
down Hamas and occupy that area
Hezbollah will have to enter they will
not allow Hamas to fall they basically
have an informal treaty and then what
can Hezbollah do they are so much
stronger than hamas's armed Wing they
can actually do targeted strikes
throughout Israel
they uh gave Israel a bloody nose in
2006 Israel failed to defeat
them uh and I don't know where that will
lead it could it could then lead
to more forces intervening because that
be that'd be sun Shi then agreeing with
each other if hisbah and Hamas agree
that Sunni and Shia Muslims agreeing to
be against Israel right so isn't that
open a whole another cem of War as well
it's like with Iran backing Hamas which
is Shia and Sunni Etc wouldn't that's
that's a whole thing in itself already
well that's a that's a great question to
raise because Saudi Arabia which we had
thought of as sort of the the the the
real Sunni power that was supporting the
overthrow they were supporting the
overthrow of Syria they're different now
Muhammad bin Salman has kind of turned
his back on the West and his statement
on what happened on October 7th uh the
attacks inside Israel was kind of he
didn't condemn it he said we just call
for peace and Washington's furious at
him um you know our gas prices are going
up right now yeah he's he's he's not
he's not opening up the tap he's pissed
off what's the story of Hezbollah who
are they where do they come from
Hezbollah is a Shia faction in Lebanon
uh that
was really formed in the 1980s when
Israel invaded Lebanon Israel thought
that the Shia because they were a
minority that had been mistreated would
be their allies and that they would
greet them with candy but then the
Israeli forces started abusing them
Hezbollah formed uh after the Iranian
Revolution with some support from Iran
and they became one of the most powerful
forces in resisting Israel as it
consistently attempted to occupy and
reoccupy Lebanon and they are
responsible for forcing Israel out
completely in 2000 they acquired
anti-tank weapons uh they were um
training in combined arms tactics and in
2006 Israel again attempted to destroy
Hezbollah remember condar rice called it
the birth pangs of a new Middle East um
basically a test case for the war with
Iran and they repelled Israel when
Israel came in again with tanks um and
Hezbollah has only gotten stronger they
are led by a political Wing Hassan
nasala is their spiritual leader and he
is an he is an ally of Iran but not a
proxy he's very in some in many ways he
can influence the Strategic calculus
that Iran makes and they do also have
Christian supporters because uh they are
in in in they're like a state within the
Lebanese State and they prioritize
resisting Israel which is really popular
there whereas the Lebanese Army is
totally trained by the us just like the
Palestinian Authority they're there just
to keep the peace they don't do anything
when Israel attacks and Israel has done
so much damage to Lebanon that that
Hezbollah is just popular and Hezbollah
intervened in Syria in order to defeat
Al-Qaeda I actually went to one of the
villages where they intervened called
malula which is the oldest Christian uh
settlement in all of the Middle East
actually uh The Passion of the Christ if
you saw that all of the extras from The
Passion of the Christ came from malula
they speak um Aramaic W one of the last
places in the world arame is spoken and
Al-Qaeda took over wow Turkish NATO
backed forces of al-Qaeda and katar back
and they took the nuns hostage so uh and
and Hezbollah came in and liberated that
town so can we pull Christian Town pull
up this uh we have this map here and uh
take a look at Iran look where Iraq and
Afghanistan are most people don't know
their geography no and so uh when you
wonder about the US involvement in
Afghanistan and Iraq and uh uh the US
has uh consistently been trying to uh
you know what what whatever you want to
say like they these these elements
within the US government want war with
Iran and when you understand the uh uh
cutter turkey pipeline as one small
story and all of this I would I I I
would say on the surface it seems that
all of this everything we're talking
about is about supplying Europe with
cheaper energy to compete with us
adversaries yeah controlling the trade
rout would you agree or what do you
think um when the US began sanctioning
Venezuela and Iran it had to then take
its oil from Russia right and now we're
sanctioning the crap out of Russia so
the oil prices are going up and Europe I
mean they're screwed Germany doesn't
have a plan B you know the green party
is in part of is in their governing
Coalition they wanted to take even
nuclear offline now they're bringing
what 26 Coal Fired plants back on but
why why are they doing that why why not
just go nuclear because they're the
green party I mean it's completely
ideological this is insane um so the
point is more people need to hear that
this is this is blowing back this this
entire drive for war with Iran regime
change in Venezuela having uh you know
turning Ukraine into an Unsinkable
aircraft carrier it's destroying it's
destroying Europe which the US kind of
likes for now because we sell them our
liquid natural gas that they weren't
trying to buy but it will eventually
come back here and it's hurting the
American Consumer already every body's
feeling it so uh we can pull up the map
real quick for those that uh don't
understand there was a story I think it
was in 2012 the guardian reported that
as of 2009 us intelligence wanted to
destabilize Syria because we wanted to
build an a a natural gas pipeline from I
believe it was the Persian Gulf through
Iraq was it the Persian Gulf it was it
was through Iraq through Syria through
turkey into Europe uh spec partly or I
should say majority of the the largest
reason why was to offset the Russian gas
prom natural gas Monopoly Syria said no
Syria is allied with Russia and outright
refused to allow this of course they
also have Russia as a military base in
Tartus which is uh where's there it is
right right here Y and so uh uh
conveniently for the United States
whatever you believe Syria falls into
civil war with the United States on the
side opposing Assad whatever side that
may be and uh uh it it seems like now
with Ukraine with barisma all of these
things are deeply connected to we are
trying to get cheap energy into Europe
it's a very simple way of putting it
nordstream gets blown
up yeah where's the US military in
Syria it's in the Northeast where all
where the Koko oil fields are well Trump
trump told us
that jeez well Trump tried to pull them
out yeah they lied about it if I
understand correctly they're actually uh
they were in Iraq based in Iraq and and
going to Syria from Iraq but if I and
and Trump wanted to get our troops out
of Syria it's really funny because when
was the for formal Declaration of
deployment right it's like just all of a
sudden it's like we have troops in Sy
it's like wait when well the thing is
but the re the reason that there the
reason there was no declaration is
because it was special forces so it was
like Delta and stuff so those dudes they
don't and then they lied to the American
people because Del the American people
voted for a president who was saying no
more to these Garbage Wars you know what
grinds my gears that that was that was
me when in 2008 Barack OB OB and I was
and and and you know I very much was
listening to what Ron Paul was talking
my friends were all very into Ron Paul
and then when it came down to the actual
election my friends just like dude he's
clearly not like the establishment this
is our one chance and I was like okay
whatever I mean I'm in Chicago I'll vote
for him I don't know if it means
anything and then he went what was one
of the first things he did was he bombed
a village of women and children I think
killed 23 or something like that in
Yemen inida right was perhaps all I know
is I'm at these anti-war protests
they're saying George W bush is Hitler
and then Obama's like Obama yeah I
thought we were talking about the Trump
era sorry oh no no Obama did yeah yeah
so George W bush they're calling him
Hitler they're waving these signs and
they with the Hitler mustache so I'm
like okay well I'll vote for Obama and
then I think it was like within a few
weeks actually I think it was like three
days later after his inauguration women
and children killed 23 or so and then I
was just like oh okay no that was well
there's a lesson learned that was my
ticket out of the democratic party
forever was no that was me right I was
just like oh so everybody just lied to
me and I'm an idiot I was pissed and
then I didn't vote again for 12 years
well I mean it was so much crazier than
like just believing in it it was like he
got a Noel prize before he came in a
Nobel Peace Prize I almost I I I was
really really really upset when that
happened because I was like he literally
did nothing this means this is
cheapening the value of every single
Nobel that has been given up before
right he got an award for being not
George Bush and there was no no reason
to believe other than you know he had a
nice smile and was charismatic there was
no reason to believe that he was going
to have any different policy there was
no CH and there was no change in fact he
shot just as many missiles and violated
the Constitution just as badly and worse
he killed he killed I think he killed
more American citizens than any other
president I mean I think he's the well
he's the only guy that ever targeted
American citizens openly without yeah
and and targeted him without without
judicial you know without due process
what what it just I'm just so disgusted
by all this man the the the the idea
that we've talked I can't remember who I
was arguing with but they were saying
that the president has a wide uh what's
what's the uh birth not birth but like a
mandate in terms of defending this
country and if that means American
citizens overseas I'm like no it doesn't
that is so that is such fabrication to
to apologize for the guy they like doing
illegal that's all it is dude I'm
sick of this too and I've been thinking
okay Federal Reserve formed in 1913
World War I begins in 1914 maybe a
coincidence maybe World War II ends in
1945 Israel is formed in
1947 maybe probably okay I'm done with
the coincidences now the British and the
French wanted that area of the world
it's we've been In Perpetual War for 115
years this is one war it started in 1914
we're still there we're still in it no
no it's not one it's been cold for a
while it's been proxy it's the same
thing man you can reduce it all
the way back thousands of years began in
1914 with this banking take over it
didn't I you know you know what really
frustrates me as I'd Occupy Wall Street
and they were having a general assembly
meeting to determine what should be the
goal and one guy stands up waving his
arms like you just did said fracking is
everything why can't you see no I'm not
saying the conflict began in 1914 I'm
saying this war the Great War began in
1914 and it has not ended the reason
World War why the alliances form why why
did the because they wanted to control
the world with economy man no no no why
why did the alliances form that led to
World War I uh cousins birth rights
money the conflict well before this you
can get as reductive as you want it goes
back forever but the banking cartels the
bank for international settlements the
Federal Reserve was formed in 1913 and
it set the world Napoleonic Wars and and
and uh what was it the Rothschild yeah
the legend of coming back and say Yes
Napoleonic wars were European Wars yeah
and what do you think World War I was a
global war with what what
countries it was mostly based in in it
was mostly based in Europe and World War
States it's when you took when North
America got involved it when we started
calling them world wars and with World
War II you had the Japanese empire which
was relatively separate from what the
the the what was happening in Europe but
yes even the Napoleonic War as you could
argue was like World War these countries
had colonies everywhere Australia New
Zealand there's there's french
uninhabited islands near Antarctica yeah
like so it was World War it's been been
colonization since like the 1600s and
when when when theen when the French
Empire was at war with all other
countries of Europe that included all of
their colonies around the world as well
they fought were there too there was
they fought against the Russians the
Dutch Ian what you I think what you're
you're describing is the fact that the
when the Federal Reserve came into being
it allowed the government to print money
which allowed the government to finance
War right and also profit off of it I
don't know that that's the case because
I think that they could profit off of
War long before the Federal Reserve but
you get to blow things up and then loan
them give them as much of your money as
you want your Fe I mean anyway start
interrupt maybe but the but the point is
that the the existence of the Federal
Reserve
unleashes and and basically not just the
Federal Reserve but but money that's not
actually tag pegged to uh to Gold they
can manipulate it much easier if they're
printing money that's not pegged to Gold
but the existence of the Federal Reserve
is what really gave governments the
specifically the United States
government the ability to fund Wars and
when you have the ability to fund Wars
then they'll go ahead and they'll look
for reasons to go to war but it's not
like all the wars that you're describing
are not the same thing I think it's all
one war they say World War I and World
War II it's semantic in my
op then then then you need to go back
further than that you need to go back to
where these alliances come from I'm
talking about this war is began 1914
this war this is a World War it's been
going on for 110 years and it's Banker
control okay you are ignoring the
history of Europe there's other Wars
that have happened I'm not saying that
this is the first war I'm saying it's
the first we're still in this war it
hasn't stopped yet it's been cold it was
cold and now it's a cold war with China
and it's like been proxy Ian when you
say China's involved in the same War you
need to go back they were involved in
World War I you are choosing to
hyperfocus on the bank because that's
what you care about this this banking
War started in 1914 no it didn't no I
don't think when do you think that the
Federal Reserve War Began before the
Federal Reserve existed like what are
you talking about think the you are you
are the Federal Reserve is a symptom a
creation because of these things I
meaning the history started that
freaking thing to control people you're
ignoring where they're where they come
came from and where their wealth comes
from and what conflicts they were
involved in you are choosing to hper on
the Federal Reserve because that's your
thing but bro all of this is reductive
no no it's not man it's a war and it's
semantic to call the Cold War not World
War World War I is the Cold War it's the
same so Ian the but the the the the
world wars of the 20th century were Wars
of ideology it was really people
figuring out because in the in the 18th
or in the 19th century
um you had the basically the the
Industrial Revolution made it possible
for people to not live just agrarian in
an agrarian society you had people going
to cities and stuff you had this massive
explosion in people that could be become
philosophers and blah blah blah and so
in the 18 in the 19th century there was
a lot of philosophers they were they
came up with the ideas of socialism
fascism was was was the idea was was
created liberalism was was a creation
that was also in the 18th century and
and the wars of the 20th or 19th century
I'm sorry the wars of the 20th century
were kind of or at least the first half
were kind of trying to hash out what
what system works best you had socialism
you had fascism you had liberalism and
it the way that it worked out at the end
of the 20th century is it looked like
liberalism probably was the best system
for for Humanity because it allows
people to make mistakes without having
it being a top down control so what
you're describing is really more of
humans trying to figure the best way to
to organize their societies and and
fighting over the way to organize it
because you went from Total War
feudalism in the in the 19th century and
then you went into capitalist societies
and then that that's where you had
enough production where people could
start to you know just talk about
Socialism or Fascism and whether the
state should be in control or whether
the individual should be in control but
these things are all symptoms or the the
wars that you're talking about are all
symptoms of trying of of humans trying
to figure out the best way to organize
their society we're currently in fascism
right now and it's not working very well
we're not in fascism right now we are
private corporate let me let me finish
this because I want to go on but there's
a war between England and France called
the Hundred Years War Wars can go on
that long so just consider that maybe
we've been in like it's not normal to be
at War like we're not in how long was
true war is the war is the norm for all
of human history don't think so it
absolutely is I mean you weren't there
how do you know I I don't think we have
to be at War so we've been in a war my
whole life okay but we've just been
winning it the whole time we we've been
we've been in a Siege where America has
150 military bases controlling people's
behavior war and violence are the norm
for Human
Society peace is extremely rare and we
are living in an anomalous time where
generally our society is at peace now
the world's not I I know I know that
it's not the world that's why I'm saying
our society Western
atace andalous is
notal hisory at War there has been if
you look at human history it is drenched
in Blood and made of piles of bodies the
fact that we can get up in the morning
and not worry about
dying like I'm not in that place anymore
a huge huge it's it's totally unique to
our time and place I don't feel that I'm
worried about that's
fine pretend like we're not is just a
ticking Time Bomb I I understand what
you're saying but I'm trying to what I'm
trying to do is give you a little
perspective and or to to pull you back
from the brink because we are actually
in one of the most peaceful times in
human history we and and human history
is full of War we're going to jump to
the story from Politico RFK Jr super
pack raises $1 million within hours and
courts Elon musk's support just hours
after RFK junr and announced he would
run for president as an independent more
than $1 million gushed into the coffers
of a super pack supporting him American
values 2024 said it raised 11.28 million
in just 6 hours following Kennedy's
announcement in Philadelphia on
indigenous people's day are they
seriously going with that Politico I
it's Columbus day isn't
it according to press release millions
of independent-minded Americans are
seeing through the most powerful
censorship and propaganda campaign
against any candidate in American
political history said Tony Lions
co-founder of the pack in a press
release they are angry at the DNC for
attempting to disenfranchise them eager
to support an honest Democrat and more
open than ever before in American
history to an independent and honest
candidate so uh I guess I'll just throw
it to you Max I'm curious what your
thoughts are on RFK uh RFK Junior's
announcing he's running I do you like
the guy do you think he's going to pull
votes from Biden or Trump I mean I
personally like him I really hit it off
with him I felt like he was a
like-minded person when I met with him
and I've been interviewed by him he's
completely woke in the good way of woke
on Ukraine on issues of Iraq Afghanistan
and his opening speech for his campaign
was in many ways inspiring I mean I
thought it was a great anti-war speech
and he brought up his uncle's uh wish to
scatter the CIA into a thousand pieces I
mean that was the message we needed to
hear since then his campaign has been
completely deflated within the anti-war
movement since he took on this uh ludic
kind of Extreme pro-israel Dimension to
it which and started to seem like he was
agitating for war with Iran didn't see
in his speech yeah yeah I mean if you
watch he did this weird event with schmi
boak who's this kind of like Rabbi runs
around calling everyone an anti-semite
who won't do what he wants um he's paid
by Sheldon Adon who was one of the
biggest individual donors to Trump who
came in through Jared Kushner and it was
a weird event I was like did you get
paid to do that like is there some kind
of incentive for you to take on this
non- anti-war line because you see I
mean if if you're that pro- Israel
you're not going to like hang out with
me you know who I am and it just seems
strange to me so I there's just been
this feeling of deflation within the
kind
of anti-war movement anti-war
Independent Media uh within the sectors
of the left that initially supported him
the Grassroots left and yeah the
Democrats were always going to screw him
over yeah and now the question is what
is he going to do as an independent
because we knew we know he was one of
the boldest people in America speaking
out against the propaganda and scoping
of the country during the coid event
that would seem to drain from Donald
Trump if he was an independent or
whoever the Republican a disantis and i'
I mean hasn't he I've heard that one of
his his recent rallies he's been
attacking Trump in a more strident way
so well it's it's unclear what he's
trying to do here but you're you're
you're not you're not voting for
him I I mean I I can't see myself doing
that but I I don't really it doesn't
matter who I vote for because I live in
DC well sure sure but I mean in terms of
your your moral compass and your heart
uh if if Trump beats Biden how does that
make you feel or if Biden beats Trump
like do does it matter to
you I mean it it it matters but I I mean
not I can't see myself voting for either
of them but what I I mean just looking
at it from a more objective point of
view not
me I think this election is so much
about whether you trust the system or
not and a lot of and so many people just
simply don't trust the system are going
to vote for Trump just to give the
finger to the system because not because
they like him uh the indictments a lot
of people who've been screwed over by
the criminal justice system who are not
traditional Republicans are starting to
sympathize with him the things he says
about the system about the Deep State
the National Security State um the media
everybody hates the media it's the it's
the worst I mean having been in the
media for 20 years it's like you get all
the worst people in the country in one
place and then just let him go crazy and
dominate your mind so Trump is the I
mean I I I loved when he would call the
media the corporate media the enemy of
the people so this and this is all this
is about that and the people have the
most to lose from the loss of
establishment control
financially tend to be the Democratic
party donor class I think so I think I
think he's you you can't pull from Trump
for the reasons you just described I
mean my my my attitude toward Trump is I
I just think he's the best bet in terms
of firing people you know I I think
Ronda sandz is a negotiator I I I like a
lot of his policies I think he's running
a bad campaign and I think he goes to DC
and then he just says you know let's
let's just negotia and playball
unemployment yeah Donald Trump I think
is just at this point he wants revenge
that's the joke we make we made the
poster of him this say revenge on it and
if he fires a bunch of people I'll take
what I can get I don't like when it was
Trump versus Hillary I just thought it I
thought it was WWE it was garbage like
Hillary Clinton is a psychopath she's a
sociopath she wants to murder people she
was the she was Secretary of State under
Obama and all of that Bloodshed I'm like
Libya yeah I'm in New York you're not
getting me to vote for this even Obama
knew she was crazy yeah dude yeah he
wouldn't let her buddy Sydney Blumenthal
work with uh uh in the government and
Sydney's like a Gunrunner he he wanted
to set up ospr Global Solutions in Libya
and he was like a longtime adviser of
the clintons and Obama's like I don't
want him anywhere near here Hillary but
she was having secret emails with him
and like doing what he wanted to get his
company set up in Libya when we took
over just a dirty dirty dirty woman but
I mean I I wonder if uh I mean I I I
have to feel like you're not a trump guy
but you'd have to think Trump is better
than
Biden um I don't think Trump is better
than Biden based on him bringing okay I
know I know Bolton what do you mean
better than Biden well I mean look Joe
Biden is the perpetuation of the
establishment warmonger Warhawk garbage
neolib neocon machine and Donald Trump
is an extremely imperfect loud mouth who
at least told us a bit of the truth
tried to get our troops out of
Afghanistan and Syria and no new Wars
so if it's like if you don't like his
policies if you don't like his character
if you don't like his attitude I I can I
understand this libertarian argument
where they're like Trump is bad here all
the really bad things he did and I'm
like and isn't doesn't it suck that he
was better than all the rest and they're
like well that's not saying much I'm
like but it is saying something I mean
there are things Trump did that I found
absolutely horrible like trillion dollar
tax cut is from where I'm coming from
it's it's just uh fueling the economic
crisis people are in and where I live in
W 88 and DC I mean you just see total
toal desperation there is no program no
there's no social safety net for anyone
and it's fueling homicide people just
don't care anymore Donald Trump did some
off you know he he brought John Bolton
in he brought Nikki Haley in he brought
HR McMaster in he brought Jared Kushner
in he let Ivanka show him pictures of
Syrian children supposedly and then
acted on a false flag to fire missiles
so can you really trust him obvious what
the establishment is afraid of with
Trump is is not what he does it's what
he says and then with Biden well we see
what we get with
Biden and seriously and to your and and
to your point before I mean you know you
should play the man not the ball I mean
I you should judge you can judge me uh
based on my work and the things I do I
think that's only fair I think all those
criticisms of trump are absolutely fair
and then it's still like he crossed the
DMZ into North Korea and it's like no
new Wars perpetuation ofor for sure uh
an effort to wind down and get us out of
Afghanistan when he he brought the
Taliban to Camp David he got attacked
for it and I'm like negotiate negotiate
we're done with this and uh he tried
getting our troops out of Syria except
for the oil and they lied to the
American people about it and my attitude
is just I'm not saying you have to
support him or like him but it's like
and you don't have to comment at all
that's up to you I'm just saying for me
I look at it like yeah Trump may be in
general bad I don't know if a president
could be good but he's better than that
than he's the best president I've had my
life no I understand why people feel
that way as a journalist I'm just not
going to be drawn into being like a
court voice for for a candidate it's
because they're always going to
disappoint you what Trump shows is just
he he he lifts the mask on the fact that
there is what you could call a deep
State I I just loved when he was in it
like he was in front of the helicopter
or whatever and he was like we're doing
this weapons dealing with Syria it's
going to be great for the ecademy and
then all the anti-war left they were
just like he just said it he just came
out and said it what did he do with the
Drone weapon program uh Luke was saying
on the show that he gave control of
drone assaults to the generals like so
he he no longer made the decision of
who's going to die he just so he's like
I he kind of washed his hands of it and
gave what what was that exact I mean I
know that he gave the CIA unprecedented
powers to carry out Black Operations
including assassinations um the CIA love
which is funny because the CIA also was
working against Trump I mean John
Brennan was running Russia gate and once
you're in the CIA you're always in the
CIA like John Brennan being former CIA
and then going on MSNBC and calling
Trump a traitor that's the C he's
speaking for a wing of the CIA but
meanwhile the Black Ops guys in the CIA
were getting to do whatever they wanted
so that's not cool yeah I mean they say
no new Wars but he empowered the Deep
state by giving CIA authority to do
Secret assassinations and he also the
Abraham Accords on their face sound neat
but like you were saying earlier it it
put the Palestinian people in a in a an
ice box and gave the like the Kings of
Israel and Saudi Arabia actual not
literal Kings but the the leaders I
should say like Emirates and the wahabi
forces like the most backwards forces in
the Middle East who are the least
Democratic were going to get a complete
win-win situation under the Abraham
Accords but so much for that but so I I
just don't I don't think you can trust
what Trump will will do it was his
Personnel that really I think of fire
people his Personnel choices were
abysmal
yeah what happens if he fires people
what happens if he really starts
draining the swamp what happens if he um
goes into the state department and just
is like you're all out of here no more
USA ID none of this crap oh FBI uh
you're all you're actually going you
guys are going on trial wire tapping me
send them all to un Alaska I'm I feel
bad for the people of un Alaska when I
say I was so depressed I followed a BLM
March up Pennsylvania a and I and they
walked right by the Jay Edgar Hoover FB
bi building as if it didn't even exist
and I was like that's how I knew this
whole thing was this is the guy that
like wire tapped Martin Luther
King we're gonna go somewhere and but
anyway if Trump did that I know from a
source who was like down with Trump that
one of Trump's greatest fears was
assassination I wouldn't be surprised he
the new report is that he's he he only
uses individual bottles of ketchup that
are sealed he is not as dumb as I
thought and uh and and uh I knew people
that were on the campaign triail with
him in 2015 said he only eats McDonald's
and the joke was he just loves fast food
no the issue is that when you walk into
McDonald's the Burger's already made and
you can say that one right there and you
know it's not been tampered with whereas
if you go to most restaurants who knows
what they're doing so you're saying the
assumption is that if he tried to fire
everybody they kill him well take Reagan
being shot by John hinley to impress jod
Foster out of the equation when was the
last political assassination significant
political assassination in this country
do you mean like admitted and
acknowledged yeah acknowledged cuz
acknowledged we like then we'll then
we'll skip over JFK and we'll well we I
mean there were more recent ones than
that George Wallace oh oh sure yeah
right okay George Wallace was running as
I think an independent candidate in 72
and he was going to harm Nixon because
he had a lot of Republican you know
Southern support so he gets taken out so
you think Kennedy's at
risk Kennedy family the Kennedy family
history is not is not you know
confidence building I don't think the
Democrat are threatened by him right now
that's my sense especially as an
independent I don't and I don't think
they're threatened by Cornell West I
think Cornell West effectively dropped
out of the race yeah and he just wants
to have a platform to go around giving
talks on the show he's pretty cool yeah
he's a Cool's very wonderful human being
but he doesn't have a platform right he
just makes proclamations and uses a lot
of isms which is disappointing to me
because he's someone I have so much
common ground with but I don't think
there's a threat right now to the
establishment other than Trump and
obviously Trump's kind of like the front
runner so what will they do if he
actually fulfills those promises if he
goes like dark Brandon
[Laughter]
Trump is that a rhetorical question I
mean yeah I'm just putting it out on the
table so I don't have to do Alex Jones
said that his plane would go down and a
plane crash that's how that they would
kill him I don't know and like a lot of
people would
celebrate that would be it is terrifying
like trying to destroy it doesn't make
any sense to destroy the system right
now it just doesn't make any sense the
system's the least worst system on Earth
it's horrible in a lot of ways but it
yeah system works it's just the people
in the system that are that are the
issue people in the system are not
become Wicked people become Wicked the
systems become Wicked you know what is
it Creed I'm saying the people that are
in the system are who become Wicked the
system itself I agree it works but
that's why that we saying fire people
we're not saying you rid of the
positions um well some people are saying
yeah I was going to say yeah yeah I know
but uh generally speaking yeah I agree
the system generally works because it's
checks and balances Etc but there are
people in there that have made it so
that their checks and balances kind of
you know even out in favor of them the
end I think there are predators yeah and
they view the world very animalistically
yeahh and so the attitude of so many
people in power is all that matters is
power yeah you know and and then there
are the classically liberal individuals
and I don't mean the literal political
liberal I mean people who hold some of
these traditional American views of
honesty Integrity negotiation
cooperation which uh exists in a lot of
different you know uh uh perip
peripheral uh political philosophies and
these people think they're playing a
good fair game with the Predators who
are laughing behind their backs this is
speaking of the history of our nation
and predatorial behavior how they're
like land grab and they're like well
there's people there no they're not real
people they're called Savages just take
the
land but that's the story of History
again that's like it's not like and
especially successful governments so
like there's a deer outside my house you
know what I mean that deer is eating my
grass okay the issue is in uh if I was a
farmer and an animal W uh came onto this
land and said my family has been here
for a thousand Generations eating the
plants that grow here whose land is it
but does it belong to the deer and the
rabbits that were eating the plants or
the human who put fences around it and
said no my family gets this now there's
the deao rule of ownership which is
whoever's there and can take it and
control it and then there's the dour
type of ownership which is I have the
paperwork that says this is mine well
that's when there's a monopoly on
violence elsewhere you can appeal to
authority to come and agree with you but
uh at a certain point Conquest is is is
a real thing I think we we we're trying
to advance to a point where we resolve
matters through rules and legal channels
like I was mentioning classically
liberal approach but I I don't think you
get rid of Predator predators and if
they if they can't use Force they'll use
coercion they they'll use soft power
Jordan Peterson talks about the the way
that we interact as a game right so we
all kind of decide that we're going to
play this game and we agree to the rules
and if you're a liberal and you live in
the United States and and you want to
have a normal kind of life you will
abide by the rules of the game the
people that don't want to abide by the
rules of the game actually are the
people that have more power than the
people that want to abide by the rules
you if you if you decide you don't want
to play and you want to use violence to
acquire things the rest most of the
people are going to say well we have a
we have a a a situation that or we have
a a a process to take care of that and
that's police and that's the the
judicial system Etc um but at the end of
the
day that only works because you have
people that are willing to use violence
and force to make the person that
decided to step outside of the rules of
the game play by the rules and the Only
Rule when you get once you step out
outside of the rules of the game then
the rules are just violence so max was
talking earlier today about about the
the behaviors of of the Palestinians and
they they don't have any recourse Etc
and so they're choosing violence but
once you choose violence then it's just
a matter of who's got more power in my
opinion for the Palestinians to choose
violence is a terrible decision because
they're going to get the stomped
out of them because of the fact that
Israel just has more military power
whether or not that and I'm I'm not
talking about right or wrong I'm just
saying the actual conditions ma said
actual political power comes out of the
barrel of a gun and in you know Starship
Troopers the violence is the ultimate
Authority that that all other authority
gets its power from and that is actually
true and so you have to decide do you
want to play by societ do you want to
have a society that has rules and has
people that play by the rules or do you
not I mean in in a fair Society you have
a choice
they didn't have I mean they chose
initially they attempted to choose
negotiations look what happened with
Oslo they got record amounts of
settlements built immediately in their
territory like literally in their olive
olive Groves and backyards so they
weren't living in a society that they
had any control over yeah I'm I'm I
understand that and I didn't mean to to
pick on what you were saying I was just
talking about just a concept of what is
a society or what is a citizen I mean
being a citizen is you have the right to
have rights and you know theoretically
we have that here we have a constitution
but more that's the game we play that
more than ever our rights are determined
by a donor class and an unelected group
that's deeply embedded in the government
that we can't even see well should
that's what I think has caused a
political realignment by the way where a
lot of people on the left and right who
see that are moving away from these
traditional labels of left and right and
forming a coalition against what people
crudely would call the Deep State yeah
that's what we did at the rage against
the war machine rally in February he put
aside the Left Right Boutique cult War
differences and just come together
because the the the fight against the
Ukraine proxy war really was a fight
against those elements they've created
this war not us the people didn't vote
for it and what Russia created the war
what's the war really about I mean it is
about the banks it is about one of our
only productive Industries getting
flooded with Investments the arms
industry we don't make stuff like we
used to in the us but we make weapons
and uh
Russia Russia brought it brought it hot
but war is war man yeah when you Siege
someone and you hold them in their house
and and then they break out and make it
hot it's like well that that's NATO on
the doorstep man that's and that's
Israel putting these people in a little
open air prison you know you you put
them right up against the wall and you
don't let them move like eventually if
they lash out who's I'm talking about
Russia invading Ukraine was turning a
conflict hot that had already been
because because we' pushed NATO East and
and this the same thing with the
Israelis pushing the Palestinians into
Gaza like you push them into it and you
don't give them any other opportunity
like they lash out we the same thing
we're going to go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you like it
and head over to
timcast.net profits and things like that
and I'll keep doing it Mr Mr batalon
says fun fact as per the Geneva
Convention protected locations lose
their protected status I.E schools and
hospitals if they are used for military
purposes military operations correct
yeah fix banet says Hamas named their
attack after the AL AXA mosque I won't
be surprised if civilians tear it down
the Israelis would then be able to build
the Third Temple watch for the temple
Institute sacrifices the red heer I
don't understand that red heer has to do
it's like the it's I'm trying to
remember this exactly but it's a it's a
significant religious symbol I can't
remember what it is exactly I can help
with that thank you uh if I'm going to
probably get it wrong but basically you
need the blood of a red heer for um Jew
to be able to enter the compound uh and
it's hard to get a red haer there so
well all right Noah Sanders says Tim
what happened to the Michael Cipher on
censored episode I went to find my clip
of saying he should do a shark tank not
even an hour after he announced on IRL
and it wasn't working what's up uh I
don't know you you want to take that
note down the Michael Cipher members
only and see if there's something up
with it later on we'll try we we'll get
that sourced our crew is probably
already on it because we have a crack
team that is working to bring you only
the best content at
timcast.net pick on Ian cuz you know
insecurity issues I do love how
polarizing you are with like there's a
bunch of people being like you're so
smart and you're so knowledgeable and
others being like you're a you're a
fraud and a sham you really you you you
did it I guess are they mutually
exclusive uh I think the over
overwhelming majority of people are just
watching like the people who comment are
like the top tier politically active
individuals and they're going to have
very strong opinions yeah 85% of people
who are watching are just like huh Max
I'll look I'll see what this guy's
writing about and they'll you know Matt
Gates pointed out that our audience is
super rational and super like logical
and when he bumps into he's like you you
you bump into like a Fox News viewer and
they're like hey I saw you on TV once
you bump into a timcast viewer and
they're like I thought about everything
you said and I've written down this plan
so much more uh you know
involved let's grab some more what is
this idg says Brett Weinstein Tucker V
Bannon Alex Jones Dave Smith Etc are all
coming to the conclusion that Israel had
four knowledge of the attack but stood
down and allowed it to happen change
your mind uh I think I think that uh I
would lean slightly away from uh from
that I guess you could say this I think
it is completely reasonable to believe
that to any degree be it small or great
Israel did have for knowledge of
something to then say that Israel stood
down and allowed like these attacks and
killings of civilians I I would lean
against I have no evidence but it is
completely within the realm of
reasonability for a country to allow a
thousand of their citizens to be raped
and murdered and captured in order to go
to war to destroy an enemy they want
annihilated I completely agree it's
called false Flags countries. history uh
have have utilized this governments I
should say have utilized this tactic but
uh I I I do I don't I actually think
it's not the simple answer right I think
if we go by aam's Razer it's Hamas like
you said like the targeting of civilians
is leverage for them to negotiate the
release of of their people so a mil
operation makes more sense and uh I I I
suppose you could say Israel doesn't
need this degree of conflict in order to
justify what they're doing especially as
as you mentioned they shot people who
are unarmed and there was no outcry over
it Israel has uh something called the
Hannibal directive in its military which
allows the military to kill its own
soldiers if they become captive if they
are held captive because the political
price of them being held captive is so
high you know they'd have to exchange
thousands of prisoners or who knows what
and there's evidence that they have
enacted the Hannibal directive and
attacked um Hamas vehicles that were
carrying soldiers back live soldiers
back into the Gaza Strip so I'm not I
think that cuts against the theory that
they allowed this to happen because
their fear of one soldier being captive
is so extreme within the mil the um
Military Intelligence establishment in
Israel and now they have dozens and
dozens we don't even know how many yeah
I I think
typically the the false flag narratives
while possible are usually on the more
complicated solution as opposed to The
Simple Solution and The Simple Solution
when when uh uh when can what is it in
the absence of evidence the solution
that makes the least amount of
assumptions tends to be
correct Israel and Hamas conflict Hamas
wants uh captives for uh they they take
civilians they take soldiers they use
them as political uh uh uh bargaining
chips much much simpler and least amount
of assumptions as as opposed to Egypt
warrants Israel Israel says aha now's
our chance we'll utilize this to there's
also this this image of Israel that they
Market to the world that they have the
best intelligence services that they
they're the surveillance Masters I mean
they make they they do their economy
thrives off of selling their spy Tech
abroad I mean they have an entire unit
called Unit 8200 that goes into the tech
sector afterwards I mean they did that
um they were uh the founders of black
Cube the company that Harvey Weinstein
used to tail his accusers they're making
so much money as consultants so everyone
thinks they're so brilliant and we
overestimate them in fact they're kind
of a paper tiger and they just got
humiliated by a bunch of guys on
motorcycles yeah but the conspiracy
theorist that people that hate Israel
they're really good at telling people
that the Mad know everything too JFK
yeah there's there's a lot I mean so
maybe we overestimate it but it's not
that it's overestimated just because of
the people that are like in supporting
Israel or Israel it's like the people
that hate Israel loved they they'll tell
you Israel did everything you know my my
my timeline on on Twitter has been full
of like but don't you know the Jews
control the Sun and blah blah you know
all kinds like man yeah so it's it it it
is it is it is definitely something that
the conspiracy theories have globbed on
to and really push as well as and it's
and you know they're not going to stop
they're not the the mad and and Israel's
intelligence service they're not going
to be like no no no they like they like
it yeah absolutely the drum Knight says
war never changes I love this one it's a
line from Fallout where I think it was
Ron Pearlman right did the vo and he's
like war never changes and it's just
like War changes all the time dude come
on like I just I always hated that line
in Fallout war never changes what are
you talking about there's all sorts of
developments like gorilla Warfare was a
major Advance scorched earth like War
changes a lot digital Warfare inform
aerial Vehicles who invented oh yeah
right Israel invented them but I suppose
the argument is that it's always just
about killing and destruction but yeah I
still got to say eventually it's gonna
be robots fighting robots it's gonna be
yeah like our drones versus their drones
yeah I mean you see it over Israel with
the Rockets versus Rockets almost it's
machine on machine yeah
crazy all right where we
at let's grab this one Glenn manal says
breaking points had a good video on
debunked videos and photos a circulating
video was a video game screenshot be
wary of the fake stuff yeah that's what
I'm talking about if a reporter comes
out and says I'm hearing babies were
beheaded I'm like okay well a qu hearing
something and an official statement from
military or spokesman or something so
I'm evidence is very very I'm expecting
to see a blurry image of a baby with a
head in the next week or two I just
bought a bunch of these by the way
they're really good spin dend we don't
have any up here I got no we should
though so be wary of seeing something
because there could be false or deep
faked images of babies with heads cut
off just be very you might start seeing
images in the next 3 to five days two
weeks to to verify the claim they're not
maybe they don't show it all at once
maybe it's legitimate I don't even know
yet Alexander Al says has Tim Gone full
neocon yet no but between Cassandra
Fairbanks and elad eliyahu man I'm being
ripped in two
directions wow yeah it's funny when uh
true though yeah Cassandra uh is just so
100% purely anti- intervention at any
and and elad is he called himself the
resident neocon yeah so he's that
mustache he yeah he's a Bolton bro and
he's very much like the United States
should be the unipolar power in the
world he doesn't want other countries
getting a foothold and things like that
after having spent so much time in
Israel Max like do you what's your
Interventional stance like how do you
feel about Foreign Wars and things like
that I mean I'm an anti-interventionist
uh that's why why I'm able to find
common ground with people who are
Libertarians or conservative why I spoke
at the Ron Paul Institute is you know we
should not be over there but I also
think that's kind of an issue of like
honesty and integrity there are a lot of
people that you know we describe these
prominent left-wing personal as just
agreeing with whatever tribal position
and refusing to have conversations like
their Position will change with whatever
the narrative is like you know what uh I
I I I I I'm somewhat reling to bring it
up but progressives just means you
follow the scop at this point it doesn't
even have any principles attached to it
yeah they're like we we must support the
war in
Ukraine Nar That's The Young Turks in a
nutshell but I but I think did something
happen with Jen yuger arguing with Jen
went on Hassan show and they went at it
J was like no Hassan no Hassan was
defending uh I think the police the
police thing well I Hassan was was he
was Hassan was saying police are bad and
Jen was like releasing these criminals
is is making things worse but the
progressive narrative is no release the
criminals and it's like so but but
Ukraine I think is a really great
example of like people claiming to be on
the left if if you are if you I'm have
they called you rightwing yet oh yeah
far right right oh we got the article
together I mean come on that was that
was that was like 10 years ago after
today it's like finished what was what
was that like uh no that was like uh
that was n no what was it nine years ago
what was the article oh yeah the
Southern Poverty loss but it it wasn't
even like an splc job it was like this
weird character came in there who is
like this Anarchist freak from Portland
who had no journalistic chops and he
concocted this vast conspiracy that
involved me you like Katrina Van
yeah her Steven Walt and we were all
controlled by Vladimir Putin uh to enact
this red Brown conspiracy to like take
over alt media they had to apologize for
it it was it was absurd the splc argued
that they called me alt-right I think
and they argued that I was right-wing
their Source was no they said you went
to Iran so Iran was controlling right
right right but I think they said like
altright timpool went to Iran or
something for a holocaust denial
conference or something like this which
is just like the most insane thing
imaginable I was like I've never been
there this is crazy you should print
that article and put on the wall
somewhere yeah I think it's archived
somewhere they they to apologize for it
but it's funny I mean it was a long time
ago but I think the interesting thing is
the only I think the only thing that
really connected all of us was we're uh
uh to varing degrees but greatly
anti-war and anti- intervention yeah and
and so we're seen as we're seen as a
threat to the American order yeah I
could go deep into into that rabbit hole
but going to bore everyone watching this
but anyway I I called the Southern
Poverty Law Center and said this is
and they retracted all three
like spot but it's it's just because
they were afraid of a lawsuit good good
and uh and I should have just done the
lawsuit yeah true well I I I think I
mean it's tough because I don't I don't
think they I don't think that I don't
think you'd win that one right rightwing
is an opinion it's a nebulous statement
and that's that's why they get away with
it but I think it's hilarious how if you
are anti-war they're just calling you
right wing these days well Majin noaz
won a $30 million lawsuit against them
because they called him an islamophobe
oh so that was a characterization as
well but interesting I think no it was a
it a settlement because he actually
didn't want to go to court I think it's
I think yeah honestly I think you should
have sued and I think all of us it
should have been like a class action
well I I I got called by some lawyer or
something I I thought there was like
some lawyer involved I don't know it's
been 10 years man they got a lawyer's
letter but any anyway you're right
everyone had like a similar opposition
to the US just dominating the world
militarily and you look at China
whatever you think about China what
countries have they attacked like
recently Tibet well that's not really a
country and it wasn't any cost to them
but they're what I'm saying is they're
not going thousands of miles away and
taking over sending their troops into
conflicts like Iraq and they're not
weakening themselves they're preparing
they're buying stuff yeah they're buying
stuff they're creating infrastructure
they're cutting deals and that's how
they're going to do it with handshake
yep and the US's only move apparently is
bombs which it's just that's why I'm
like this stuff doesn't work secure our
borders build up our manufacturing base
cut these these garbage International
treaties and then lead by wealth and and
like right Prosperity yeah make people
want to be like us and build cultural
influence I guess should the Tibetan it
wasn't an invasion Chinese Invasion it
was an annexation uh Tibet used to be a
country and then at what point like 50
years ago China was just like now you're
part of China or they' just keep saying
it and tibet's like we have no voice is
that what's going on over there well the
Dal Lama was a CIA asset as were his
forces and they were being used uh as uh
the um the the weager Nationalist
movement was by the CIA to balkanize
China and China went in the population
was living under a boy King in abject
poverty and China went in and much of
the population actually welcomed them
because they started to get homes and to
be able to not worship a boy King and
have infrastructure and plumbing and
electricity uh but there's also a
Tibetan Exile nationalist movement
that's just viciously opposed to China
and where are they based here where
where's where are the Wagers based here
in Northern Virginia right near Langley
and the National Endowment for democracy
is funding all of their NOS so this
isn't a judgment on whether they're
right or wrong it's about we're going to
read some more we got this uh uh from
Alejandro Reay say boy I'm glad failed
all that REM Remains lead singer is here
for sanity sake but thank God someone is
having this argument I never was able to
have one with people I know we should
put a gold record on the wall behind you
oh yeah bring one yeah and you can hang
it up behind you when you're here right
failed on it all right we'll grab some
more Super chats what have we
here David gon gon says Tim I make metal
sculptures on my YouTube channel I made
you a momento myy mask based on stoic
philosophy it's yours if you want it oh
cool that's sick um I don't know how how
to go about sourcing that stuff though
uh tweeted Ian oh I'm open to that I
have no other response like I don't know
how to I don't know tweet at me and send
me a direct message do both Edgar Ortiz
says good on Tim for having a credible
journalist such as Max on not sure who
the other guy is though but could learn
a little something from Max you see you
get one person being like Phil you so
right about this and other person says
Max is so right about this I can I I I I
I respect the the the what so many
diverse guests on yeah I'm the failed
musician guy that's who I am oh but I
mean typically like the left doesn't
come on the show it's it's pulling teeth
it's impossible you know and so then you
know I don't know it is what it is it is
what it is it's frustrating to me
because the left could get so much more
done if it would just focus on issues
instead of virtue signaling yeah that's
which is a large component of what our
issue is y you know and so like we we we
we've had some left to on and we have
like these these like books like this
book is
where it's got explicit material and it
kids should not be exposed to some
leftists we bring on will say no I agree
you're right that book should not be for
kids I don't know why they're even
defending it I'm like well then you need
to speak up because you're you're saying
nothing and like lowering your head
while these other people we've had come
on the show just explicitly defend it
and say kids should have it and I'm like
you're just saying that because that's
the progressive line of like the
narrative that or the
scop all right what is this well that's
the that's the dividing line issue it's
like okay you're not with me on the
trans issue so we can't work together
against Ukraine to me that's so much
more
important than the trans issue and so
I'm willing to I'm willing to work on a
with a on a tactical basis with the
freedom
caucus with Marjorie Taylor green I
might not agree with her on other things
yeah but I mean avoiding World War III
might you know be pretty important yeah
I'd like to disagree later let's stay
alive and at the greyzone we we'll like
promote their initiatives to end we have
promoted Paul goar's initiative to end
uh the emergency declarations on Libya
Syria Yemen uh and this is the freedom
caucus these declarations are used to
make war on those countries and the left
is just giving them the cold shoulder
when they totally agree so I I think I I
I I think AOC is an evil person I think
she is fake I think she's just going
through the motions I don't know it's
it's I think she'll be the she'll be the
establishment she'll be the next Nancy
Pelosi she's the new Obama well there
you go or that right works yeah we need
allies now so let's let's work together
all right ptb says anyone who likes
malort hates
thems wor great I'm not trying you know
I want to be careful because I don't
want to rag on mord I'm from Chicago but
the Chicago joke is he's just says he
drinks
more uh for those that don't know malort
is like a prominent it's a well-known
lur in in Chicago it's warmwood lur
right yeah and people in Chicago think
it's horrible but they want everyone to
drink it and so they buy tons of it to
get people to drink it and the joke is
it's distilled from the grass that grows
on the side of Interstate 55 so
everybody from Chicago knows tast
like I just have it you like grass I
like all right where we at and I'm a
self-hating Jew
so do you believe God you've gotten some
of those comments for
sure in a way aside of salt let's read
this aside of salt says Hamas is in
charge of Palestine there their Charter
calls for the eradications eradication
of Jews and Christians WTF do you mean
it's not religious Max the Hamas Charter
was formally changed to remove those
anti-semitic passages in
2016 or 17 uh it's no it's no longer
there but I don't know how much time we
have I'm I would love to address the
issue of Arab anti-Semitism we we can go
we can go nuts on the on the after after
show in a few minutes we'll just we'll
we'll go deep into you know stuff and
I'm sure it will be polarizing
understood
but they did that just so that they
could attempt to negotiate with the
outside world because they recognize
it's ugly and anyway here we are all
right let's grab try and grab a couple
good ones there was one that I really
wanted to
get and uh where did it
go all right well I'll just read this
one uh dty lmw says Tim I'm begging you
please bring in a real historian that
can push back to all this nonsense this
clown is talking about as a starting
point please read and learn about the
whole history from the book the
Palestinian
delusion they can't all be praising you
for being a good journalist some of them
have to be criticisms but I'm a well
it's either real or fraud
yeah all right AB says a did I did it
just jump on me it did just jump yeah I
hate when YouTube does that yeah it's
frustrating man right there right there
oh there you go he says uh AB says Ian
you do know that Sydney Blumenthal is
Max blumenthal's father right is he
well that's why you brought it up no I
don't know are you guys related yeah
he's my father oh well so what's up what
you just talking crap about Hillary like
they're tight well I don't a I don't
agree and I speak for myself you don't
agree with your dad or you don't agree
that Hillary I don't
agree Hillary Clinton I was formally
denounced by the by Hillary Clinton in
2016 you can look that up I was
denounced by Hillary I was also
denounced by the Trump campaign I'm I
think I'm the only person to be
denounced by
Max Osprey what's they they were
basically like let's when we take Libya
let's make sure our I can't speak to any
of that but all I know is there is no
com company and no money that I know of
and uh I but I honestly I can't speak
for somebody else I'm speaking for
myself here I don't a and like I think
Hillary Clinton is a dangerous figure I
made that decision I spoke out in 2016
Jake Sullivan who's the NC director for
B Biden right now he authored the
statement denouncing me on her behalf
wow and it was because she wanted
pro-israel money from her largest donor
who is named Heim Saban and you know my
my father's a complex figure he helped
start alternative media in the early
770s uh his columns on the Iraq War are
like vicious denunciations of the
neocons and in some senses yeah that
work has inspired me but I don't agree
with him on other things and I think a
lot of people watching this don't agree
with their parents right on politics so
I just uh my I I just I'm just here to
do my own work and be judged on that I
would love to have Max in here because
I've talked crap about him before you
mean Sydney uh ma man i' love to have
your dad in here if he ever wants to and
talk about it and we don't talk about
ospr he's got his uh fifth book on
Abraham Lincoln coming out so I'll
invite him oh cool oh yeah dude cuz I
mean war is the way of the world I
understand this now back I didn't before
it was like warmongers or evil stop but
now I understand the power and the the
value of force oh Ian's fullon an
interventionist just the other day he
was talking about mil he's for
intervention now he's literally trying
to make a state in the middle will state
in the middle there are times and places
when horrific things can be deterred
with Force but I would love to have that
debate with someone that's been there
and worked behind the
scenes I think the the you know we we
should find uh maybe prominent academic
count vailing views and have a larger
conversation you know God that's awes
but again I I don't think it's question
for Max just because you're related I
wouldn't you know well I mean if we if
we want to have your dad on we'll ask
your dad we don't ask you about it you
know what I mean I'll put forward a
request happy to do that yeah it'd be
great whatever you know like he's not
really in the game anymore but uh but
yeah I
uh I my work speaks for
itself that's all I got to say I mean
the fact that you that you are that
close to Hillary Clinton and our
critical I mean that's kudos to that I
mean we disagree on a lot of stuff but
Kudos I don't give a I met her once
in my life uh sorry to hear that yeah
let's uh we'll pull up the uh one more
we'll do one more Raymond g Stanley Jr
asks Tim any word on the 2A documentary
man that thing was supposed to be out
for the 4th of July yeah and then uh we
really wanted to include in certain
footage which we have to get clearances
on for copyright issues and so I suppose
it's just been delayed due to that yep
but it's fine I don't I don't think it's
a big deal actually as we're getting
into a um into the election season and
all that stuff it might be more uh um I
don't know preent or uh uh more
opportune to to wait a little bit on it
and uh you know we'll see we'll see what
happens so uh other than that smash the
like button subscribe to this Channel
and how about this we're going to talk
we're going to talk deeper on all of
this stuff in the members only
uncensored show which will be up in a
couple minutes so go to
timcast.net a member we are going to
have that uncensored show on the front
page of the website and if you join the
Discord server you can submit questions
and potentially call in to talk to us
and ask us questions you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Max do you want to
shout anything out the gry
zone.com and uh check us out on YouTube
just look up The gry Zone we we stream
every week usually Fridays we'll do
another stream on Friday and I work with
some incredible people there um you
should follow them all
um right we just do straight up
investigative journalism and we break
the media
blockade on all of these issues of War
and Peace propaganda
intelligence everything else sounds good
I am Phil that remains on Twix I am Phil
that remains official on Instagram the
band is All That Remains you can follow
us on Apple music
Spotify uh Pandora YouTube Amazon music
you know the internet and I'm Ian cross
and I'm very serious about considering
offering the Palestinian country to
become a state in the United States I
can this is the most hilarious one it's
not my idea my friend said it last night
and I I like balked at him and I shut
off the computer and I was sitting there
and then it started to all kind of form
and I was thinking of like Hawaii is so
beautiful you know that they don't want
it right I do know that I do know that
it's like it's like a less worse of
either that or do they want the carpet
bombs like what do they want let's talk
about the membership okay bye guys uh
yeah this it's been interesting um I am
surge.com uh yeah I'm excited to talk to
the members only show especially to have
this be broken down by you Max and more
so I think a lot of people don't
understand it don't know many of the
like underlying issues behind this
anyways uh we'll see about that stay
hoodie in I guess that's an interesting
take we'll see you all over at
timcast.net
I